- Smile.
(click)
- What are you doing?
- I just wanna make my
ex jealous on Instagram.
- Okay
(upbeat music)
(click, click, click)
(office noises)
- Ugh, Amanda is so annoying on Instagram.
- Why don't you just unfollow her?
- Psh, she makes me
feel better about myself.
(click, click, click)
- Ooh, ooh, upload that one.
- It's a bit late right now,
let's upload it in the
morning for more likes.
(click)
(typing)
(vibrating)
- Hey, what filter do
you think I should use?
- I think Mayfair?
Mayfair?
- No, no, no, no, no, Expro, expro.
- Expro.
- Yeah, it brings out
the def in your arms.
(upbeat music)
- I kind of like Lo-fi.
- Okay, Lo-...ooh yes, that one.
- That's the one.
- Uploading.
- Why didn't you tag me in it?
You've got so many more followers
than me, share the love.
(upbeat music)
(click, click, click)
- Oh, shit.